[Music]
and soulmate search news hmm submitted
by daily vlogger yay well if that stuff
is hard yeah yeah dude kudos to you a
man spent fourteen hundred dollars on a
newspaper ad to find his soul mate at
the advice of a sidekick
psychics are always right $1400 right
yeah does it only cost like fifty bucks
or 100 bucks to pulse' ad maybe it was
like New York Times or something I
bought like page if it's not a little
square it's like the whole page or
something do you guys believe in
psychics [ __ ] no uh yes so for me I
refuse to believe them but my mom also
has enough friends that knows some crazy
[ __ ] that I've seen in real life like
real-life David Blaine [ __ ] that kind of
freaks me out so I don't know if they're
just good at magic huh what example so
for example uh I wrestled in high school
I sprained my arm and it's hard to get
like same day doctor appointments but
then I had a tournament the next day so
my mom said oh I got this homie that
knows how to do some [ __ ] we'll fix it
all right cool whatever I'll just try
anything so she brings her over to my
mom's house first of all this lady
already looks weird she's Asian with
green eyes and my crazy dark skin and
you're just like what the [ __ ] are you
she comes in and she starts mumbling and
chanting this [ __ ] weird [ __ ] the
whole room smells like herbs immediately
like ginseng like is smokily in there
too it's like
no I just I'll just watch them in the
whole room no she comes in and she
starts chanting that the scent of the
room changes and this is my dad's house
so my mom doesn't even come to my dad's
house I'm sitting in the living room so
I know they could I know they couldn't
have prepped anything you know in the
room at least but I'm just sitting there
you know me in high school
[ __ ] like go like this with my bangs
and [ __ ] like I don't believe this [ __ ]
and then she they should go stick out
your hand so I stick out my hand and she
starts going like this and she starts
going and a pile of [ __ ] powder comes
out and it's on my hand and I'm like
what the [ __ ] you know my mom's like see
I told you I told you she told me to go
boil it I bothered I drinking my spray
one away
but to me I'm like I don't know if it's
placebo you know and I don't know like
maybe she just know some magic trick
just you know like David Blaine could do
some kind of crazy [ __ ] but all of that
it's it's explainable through logic
buddy
she's just doing this and you find out
she just crushed up some aspirin yeah so
I don't know so I've seen a lot of crazy
[ __ ] just being around my mom at her
homies but I refuse to believe it
she implanted Chinese herbs and her
[ __ ] had [ __ ] farted in the middle
of the ritual I want to believe in that
stuff I've never had any of that mystic
[ __ ] hello to Taiwan hey over mom's
friends all of her friends are [ __ ]
weirdos oh really yeah
my sister had that for me like my
sisters like all into that [ __ ] so then
she'll like get information from people
that she's close to at that time so then
this is before like had dated a Kenny
Asian guy but my sisters like oh yeah
it's almost like your friend she says
you're gonna marry a Chinese guy and I'm
like all right [ __ ] word of what
happened is that the same friend with
kind of like the lesbian haircut and the
row of bones in her necklace she looks
like a [ __ ] modern-day witch doctor
what what a [ __ ] ball in her lip and
[ __ ] the one that oh no no no no that's
it's like a [ __ ] and we let their
necklace and there's like a [ __ ] of row
of bones on there like chicken bones
like she just ate buffalo wings and made
a [ __ ] necklace out of it
no this is years look at masada bones
I'm just jealous cuz I don't have
[ __ ] psychic power so I don't want to
believe but you would believe it if I
had the powers I believe it like a
[ __ ] oh my god I would love some
powers do it so [ __ ] awesome yeah you
have the power to piss me off really
quick wait wait what happened with this
with this [ __ ] oh yeah $1,400 worth it
yeah so this is the ad that was posted
this is this takes place in Australia so
it's in the public notices right ain't
no such thing homey yeah give it to me I
read it it says here the perfect woman
searching for my princess a clairvoyant
described the following details of my
soulmate and I need Sydney's Women's
Network help to find her I don't know
her name or occupation do you know this
person
female plus single no kids age 50 to 60
but looks 10 years younger
height 162 to 167 centimeters oh five
four or five six inches feet inches
blonde the shorter length hair very
intelligent and attractive lights of the
room when she enters giggling gorgeous
has a beautiful heart warming smile
well-groomed and stylish like an airline
hostess likes wearing gloves and hats
born in Austria and has lived in
Australia for many years but still has a
slight accent a detailed everything was
like that's like 90% of you can probably
find it and it's immediately 5% in
person
you know what's funny he's literally
describing Mary Poppins oh yeah yeah
it's like a famous ackie issues from
Austria that lives in Australia worn in
Austria as living okay so it goes on
saying has a small white lapdog in as a
great cook lives in a brick house with a
backyard for the dog in western suburbs
of Sydney likes dancing outdoors sailing
cycling and bushwalking possibly a
member of Sydney Bush walkers has a
brother and or sister with children
has a good friend called Elizabeth if
you know this person could you please
send a photo of her and contact details
- like man took over while he was right
go to this psychic because she gives you
[ __ ] every day - what if this
specific person actually exists Bobby
he's just trying to act like it's a
clairvoyant I told him about her like
what if it's his actual crush but no I
don't like that's hella specific I'm
pretty sure or it's the psychic that
already had a lady in mind it's like Oh
they've been good together let me give
them detailed it's go I don't know
that's what I'm thinking $1400 because
if that's the case then that's really
really creepy how old is this guy like
70 they all we know of him is that he
goes under he's referred to light men
like men amen oh this guy sounds like
he's been alone for his whole life he's
never married because he has a [ __ ]
stewed idea of what a human being is
period we're a perfect woman yeah I like
the [ __ ] are you saying dude I kind of
wish the psychic told him about her
flaws so then we can at least see you
like if you really trying to find this
girl cuz then obviously everything that
sounds nice and perfect didn't true
she's got horrible opinions see I'm
looking for the perfect woman the one
that never knows what to eat but she's
always hungry the one that's full of
problems and no solution yeah
that turns into several different women
throughout the month always can't even
[Laughter]
even so that's the perfect woman yeah
every woman is the perfect exactly
because it's just there is no such thing
everyone is [ __ ] up in some way shape
or form Canyon is just can you tolerate
this person's fucked-up reverses this
person's fucked-up breathe you spend
enough time with someone you know you're
just gonna be annoyed at something
because in order for somebody to say I
mean people don't even think this in
order for you to say that you're looking
for somebody to be perfect you have to
realize that you have to reflect that
perfection as well yeah yeah it's like
this that means that she could be the
best human being on earth and she's
always in a good mood but that means if
you're this [ __ ] mood you still won't
meet up to your expectation of what she
knows because you're feeling bad so that
means you have to be on that same tip
yeah you know what I mean if people
don't see that a lot you know I mean and
that's where you're a [ __ ] child
people that's true in relationships too
it's kind of like if you're in the [ __ ]
mood you've dragged the other person
down with you it's late and then it's a
constant dragging each other down
eventually 20 years later
you're [ __ ] miserable both of you
guys yo no talk about math [ __ ]
wedding was beautiful
yeah you're a thousand [ __ ]
I could remember you crying so much
that's why how am I supposed to top this
yeah that's all I remember how do I
follow that yeah you don't need to say
that thing you showed it here Casey
showed it here see I can't even
well if you guys can pick one quality
that is not common amongst everyone in
your significant other not let's pretend
you guys are all single big bode no like
a personality quality yeah that's too
broad I guess I'm trying to look for
something more specific it's pretty it's
a small quality it's not we're at work
equality like like they they control
their forts I don't know some [ __ ] like
that
but like a personality trait though the
core a personality quirk I think that
sense of humor my mocha it's its sense
of humor but it's my type of sense of
humor
cuz you know it's different yeah it's
it's like what was the question exactly
yeah is it like well as a quality that
we really like it in the press yes if
you were this guy putting out an ad for
like you're searching for your soulmate
and like you have to put in a quality
that you wish this person had that isn't
as common it's like oh every anyone can
be like a wish list not generic Harmelin
exactly Oh like like likes to wear red
shoes some [ __ ] like that yeah like a
freaky thing that you would like for
your significant other
I think what it is is it's one of those
things that you don't know you like
until you meet a person that has a
quirky trait because it's so specific
that it's difficult for me to imagine
something and go I wish that the next
person I get with loves to swim
spontaneously in water fountains say in
the ocean but
yeah that's true that's a good point you
don't realize until you say it I know I
know what mine would be would be I would
want to have a girl that had it's like a
major film buff no not that not that
it's a problem or anything no cuz it was
the one I was thinking try to fix that
real quick what I was thinking which was
if it is it something that you don't
know about this person then you're
automatically gonna say something that's
something that you would like like that
you are already that you would want to
see English significant other and then
you ended up seeing that psycho [ __ ] you
all like sharing a hobby something like
I would love it if we would watch porn
together or something like that be great
I can't wear these guys coming from
though because the perfect girl he's not
meaning like the perfect girl out there
he's just mean the perfect one for him
like he's yeah what he's looking for
because like with Bart like I mean I've
told you since forever like I just
always felt like he was just like my
perfect like match you know like 99% of
it like he's like that perfect 9.99 fine
fine I never never like he has all the
qualities that I would want that I
didn't even know that I wanted that I'm
like oh wow do you want to like be part
no I was kind of sought to you because
you're saying he had qualities that you
wish you had you shut up
[Laughter]
[Music]